hey guys Greg knuckles here um I got
some footage from my training session
last night I started with bench
um and my wife was spotting me so I
didn't have anyone to take video it
didn't feel as good as the other day but
I finished with 405 for a fairly easy
double so I was pleased with that um I'm
trying to make that my daily minimum
weight that I handle pretty consistently
on a day-to-day basis and try to move up
from there
this is 495 on the squat high bar nice
long pause I'm really trying to work on
my depth because I've always squatted
just right around parallel it's just
where my my hips naturally stop me so
I've been playing with my shoes and my
stance a little bit if nothing else for
training purposes just so I can squat a
little bit deeper so I'll get more carry
over to meats when I just have to squat
to parallel this is 5:45 I felt like a
lot on my back I've got a little
strained muscle in my neck which which
made all of these squats a little bit
uncomfortable but bar speed was good
everything felt like it was moving good
it just just felt a little heavy on my
back today this is 565 this is also for
a fairly long Falls I really wanted
either six plates or 6:05 today or
yesterday I feel like it would have been
doable but I didn't have a spotter so I
didn't want to push it but you'll see
here bar speed was pretty decent just
get my hips back under it and not not
too much of a challenge to this
point and then this was 495 lobar the
unrack looks a little wonky just because
it was still set at high bar high but
it's 495 so that's something I'm going
to worry about I was happy that the
depth work with the high bar soon and
carry over pretty well to the low bar a
couple big breaths just getting
comfortable down there and that's that
good so that's all guys please like and
subscribe thanks